hey i'm ryan sickler and i want to tell
you about my patreon show the honeydew
with y'all it's just like the honeydew
but
it's with y'all if you haven't already
subscribed let me catch you up on a few
things
so far i've talked to a girl whose dad
married his stepsister you're telling me
that your dad's stepsister
is your stepmom yes they still go to
family reunions together
[Laughter]
i talked to a young man who recently
found out that his dad
yeah that ain't his dad but guess who
is remember 2018 i found out that the
guy i thought was my dad
was not my dad um and that my real dad
was actually
my friend's dad all right
all right that's also a girl who was
born with
one kidney and two [ __ ]
two [ __ ] they used to call me
dp double [ __ ]
look when i started this show never in a
million
years did i think i talked to somebody
who had two [ __ ]
ironically it was episode two look if
that's not interesting enough i talked
to a guy
who was in a coma for two months and he
died
he [ __ ] died his crane comes through
takes off this side of my face all the
way back to my ear
what my my steering wheel cuts me in
half
what see march me is dead
the honeydew with y'all
what's your story the honeydew with
y'all
subscribe today